So, today we discussed frames, which are one of the knowledge
representations that we'll see throughout this course. We started off by talking
about the basic structure of frames which involves slots and fillers, and
we talked about how similar they are to the variables and values that we see in
object-oriented programming. We then talked about the three main properties of
frames which are that they represent stereotypes of a certain concept, they
provide default values, and they can inherit from one another. We then talked
about frames in terms of other concepts we've already covered in this course.
We talked about how frames are representationally equivalent to semantic nets,
and we've talked about how frames were actually what we were using when
we were doing projection systems last lesson. We finally talked about some of
the advanced reasoning and story understanding that we can do with frames.
Now we're going to move to a topic called learning by recording cases,
where we learn from individual cases or individual experiences. But
if you're very interested in frames, you might want to jump forward to
our lessons on understanding common sense reasoning and scripts.
This will all very heavily leverage what we've learned about frames today